hey guys I wanted to do a quick video to
answer question does chocolate have
caffeine okay and the answer is yes it
does have a small amount it like one
ounce of chocolate will have anywhere
between 4 to 20 milligrams of caffeine
which is pretty small compared to coffee
or even tea but it has something else
called theobromine okay now what is that
well this is also a stimulant this is a
stimulant but theobromine is a
vasodilator okay
caffeine is a vasoconstrictor what does
that mean
it means that when something is vaso
dilated it opens up it relaxes the blood
vessel it actually will reduce blood
pressure
caffeine is constrictor it can increase
blood pressure
theobromine also is a mood elevator it
kind of brings you up okay and that's
why people consume chocolate when
they're depressed so the two big
problems with consuming chocolate is
it's hard to find chocolate without
sugar okay so if you could find
chocolate with stevia or maybe inulin or
a wreath root all that would be better
but the other problem is these two
stimulants which can keep you up at
night so if you're going to consume some
chocolate make sure it's sugar-free and
consume it earlier in the day thanks for
watching so if you're enjoying these
videos click share and spread the word